la goleta tara zarpó desde su puerto de
logia en el este de francia en su
duodécima expedición científica durante
un viaje de dos años los científicos a
bordo de este laboratorio de navegación
estudiarán el papel que desempeñan los
microorganismos marinos en el contexto
del cambio climático la tripulación
viajará 70 mil kilómetros parando en 23
puertos en tres continentes es un poco
como el siglo 19 cuando fuimos en largas
misiones de tres o cuatro años para
descubrir nuevas especies rutas
comerciales especias territorios esta
nueva aventura involucra a 42
instituciones de investigación de todo
el mundo lo que tara está haciendo hoy
en día es notable es realmente
interesante da vida a la ciencia y la
hace más atractiva desde su primera
expedición en 2006 cuando la embarcación
visito el polo norte tara ha ayudado a
mejorar la comprensión científica sobre
la contaminación de los océanos y la
forma en que el plástico afecta a los
mares durante esta última exploración el
público podrá seguir la aventura en
línea
con tara hay una cierta capacidad de
reacción rápida así que tan pronto como
encontramos algo interesante puede ser
examinado a través de imágenes de
satélite eso nos permite permanecer en
el lugar durante varios días varias
semanas para estudiar mejor lo que
encontramos y para ya ha viajado el
equivalente a diez vueltas a la tierra